darkness has descended upon the mankind
I think you know we we were trying to do
our duty as reporters 30 years ago and
maybe we just didn't do a good job now I
don't have to rely on a lazy guitar tech
to make sure that I have guitar picks
every night I just always carry a few
that I make with me out of room keys now
this is my room key for here at the
Sheraton the downside is it means there
has to be somebody behind the desk when
we get back tomorrow Devo show tonight
yeah most bands take themselves pretty
seriously you know pretty pompous
I don't think we're even supposed to be
a rock band we thought of ourselves as
like enough an Akron Ohio version of
Andy Warhol's factory only with more
important message and once you sign with
a record company they they don't want to
hear about any of that they don't even
want to know what you're talking about
things have changed for us in the last
2530 years we um you know but they have
for everybody where nobody uses tape
anymore
I think the new technology for recording
was not devised slowly and you know
evolving the way the way analog
recording did you know we're you know
you want some small consoles to bigger
consoles and everything you know small
tape decks to big tape decks and
everything had kind of a sense to it and
now it's like video game designers
designed you know the the different you
know sequencing systems and in the
different recording systems and it
doesn't seem logical sometimes but but
in speaking of logic that was the least
logical unbelievably not logical right
very only slightly more logical than
reason was unreasonable or digital
performer was unperformed well I read
something about Franz Ferdinand doing a
thing where they would loop a section of
a song and just keep playing that one
section until they thought one of the
top passes that they had was great and
then they'd go back and sort through all
14 passes and pick them on their light
and unfortunately these these techniques
encouraged artists not to make any
choice
just like ad agencies want every option
when they're on a set because they can't
commit to anything so they want to shoot
it all and then nobody can make a
decision and then somebody goes and
edits it badly
well that's what happens with music
today it's so easy to just throw another
track on you know to solve the problem
and then you have this edited this
additive synthesis that you know is
doesn't it's not always essential what
you're playing then and you have a bunch
of things that aren't intrinsically
essential in each track so that's like a
temptation to fight and after all at the
end that's what a good artist could do
is make the right decisions yeah it's
the way we even started thinking I
remember the first week that alan meyers
played drums with us we we told him he
could had to play with one hand because
we wanted to change his playing style in
the way he thought about drums and make
things more primitive and more essential
leaving things out that's what's a boy
we're not really about a certain guitar
sound necessarily or a certain voice
even necessarily we're about what was
really important I think with Devo is
what we talked about and what our
message was just like to remind
everybody that the evolution is real
it's happened and we're here as the
house band like on a titanic piece
[Music]
you
what what happened it was a real dump
there'd be when it flew away
[Music]